spencer ackerman with wires calm out in
Quantico Virginia where it's a nice if
chilly day to be blasted with a
non-lethal weapon called the Active
Denial system
it's a millimeter wave weapon intended
to cause a non-lethal but significant
burning or heating effect so for
instance if there are people
demonstrating or seeming like they may
pose a threat or not responsive to
soldiers or Marines telling them to get
back the Active Denial system is sort of
an extra step before they would actually
use lethal force
dr. war ii can you tell us a bit about
why this for instance won't microwave me
the frequency that is built into these
transmitters is 95 gigahertz that's a
factor of a hundred higher than the
microwave level frequencies that
penetrate the 95 gigahertz gives us
propagation downrange with very limited
penetration so how deep will this
actually get under my skin one
sixty-fourth of an inch let's go good
shot
you'll be a great pickup truck which is
our safety vehicle need to be backed off
the range
Oh
ha now if I didn't know where the Active
Denial system was and that it was gonna
fire I would just think this blast of
heat was coming from out of nowhere
there's no flash no smell no sound no
round and having just been blasted with
this thing I can tell you it feels not
unlike immediately walking into an open
oven door it's a little bit chilly out
here right now
and on my my chest area up to my neck I
got a big blast of heat and it forces
you to kind of immediately and
instinctually jump back you know put
your arms up you're gonna want to stop
doing what you're doing